Irishman Devin Nunez represents the
state of California the Pratt Central
Valley he is ranking member former
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee and he joins us tonight found
thanks so much for coming on great so I
don't want to put you in an awkward
situation but you serve on this
committee with Adam Schiff and and so
again if this is if awkward for you I
hope you'll just say so I'm used to
being so it's it's always awkward with
you well let me make it worse Adam
Schiff has said a couple of things in
the last 24 hours that give I think
sober people pause and and raise
concerns about his his mental fitness I
mean he suggested that the president was
for example doctoring this transcript
and then subsequently suggested that he
was speaking in some sort of secret code
what do you make of that well like many
things that Adam Schiff and the
Democrats have been saying over the last
three years it's been in Italy three
years of this Russia hoax now it's
transformed in the Ukrainian hoax they
say a lot of things that always have one
thing in common they end up being false
and they always they're very clever
because they use the things you can see
the the doors right there right it says
restricted so they'll come out of those
doors and they'll say well we've seen
some really secret stuff we can't tell
you about it but just trust us this is
really gonna be the time that we're
gonna catch President Trump with his
hands in the cookie jar that's lying
isn't it
well one person's lie is another man's
you know just trying to get to the truth
is what they would always say yeah and
look we're gonna see more of it tomorrow
tomorrow we have the Director of
National Intelligence the Acting
Director coming in to testify 9:00 a.m.
everybody's going to be watching there's
gonna be hundreds of media people there
every station is going to be covering it
live and look this is not what the
Intelligence Committee should be doing
if we want to take a whistleblower
seriously we should be doing it behind
closed doors so that we actually
actually can talk classified information
to try to determine whether or not
there's actual real if there's really
something to this complaint or not I
mean have you spoke
I mean you've been in the house for a
while and you you were community
chairman I'm you know everybody our
Democrats fully on board I mean off the
record are they saying do you boy you
know we're gonna impeach this guy and
get a conviction in the Senate do they
believe this is gonna work you know
that's that's a very good question so
the way I would say it it's about like
this you've got 30 or 40 or so maybe
maybe a few more that that have been
around a while that know what they're
doing is wrong but they're being
challenged by the left now what you also
have though is you have people who have
lied so much you know if you it's the
old saying if you tell a lie enough
eventually it becomes the truth you have
so many that have done that it's like an
everyday they're pouring gasoline on
themselves they're pouring gasoline on
the American people they continue to
light these fires out there why one for
donors they're igniting their base to
give done and you know have donors give
them money right and that's how they've
gotten themselves into this impeachment
trap which is totally irresponsible yeah
well they really don't like it when you
take power away from though I've noticed
there's no they don't want a job for
coming I know they really don't thank
you